(pensive music)
- What is it?
- It is a stapler.
- What's it do?
- There is a tube and a slide
where individual pieces of metal
are pushed forward
and then punched into the paper.
And voila, they are held fast.
- Right, and that's it?
(paper rustling)
- Worst part of my job is when a baby
gets stuck inside a woman
and I have to go in,
sometimes elbow deep,
turn their head and
shoulders and pull it out.
- Jesus, I did not know this.
- And as I'm not a vet...
- Never having children. Never.
- Hence, the mother of invention.
I have invented forceps.
(metal creaking)
In labor.
(woman screaming)
(metal creaking)
(fruit squelching)
- So much of a woman's life is wasted
being tied into and out of our dresses.
- Mm.
- As I tell my girls,
this time could be spent
reading, writing, painting.
- Indeed.
Oh!
- It is merely two strips of material
treated with tree sap that
runs the length of the garment.
And, off please.
(audience applauding)
- It is brilliant, Katya Velcra,
but let me consider the
unseen ramifications.
- And many rapes.
- I call it the Exaltation.
- Sounds promising.
- It is to be four stories
high, 70 feet wide.
One climbs this ladder to
the cart. It seats four men.
- Or women.
- Yes, women should ride it too,
as well as children.
- Wonderful.
- Now, gravity and the parabolic form
give us the momentum
for an up push, then...
(cart rattling)
(crowd gasping)
- How do they not die?
- They do.
That is the point of the Exaltation.
The journey ends in the
inescapable conclusion, death.
- What?
- The old, the infirm, terminally ill,
the suicidal, the bored,
have one final moment of sky and sun
before crashing to their death.
(whimsical music)
- We shall go with the stapler.
- Ah, bravo! We've embossed it.
- Take the "great" part off of it.
- Congratulations!